[Music]
it's shiny
it's round
it's got a hole in the middle
soft on the inside crispy on the outside
if you're thinking isn't that just a
good old bagel you're wrong
and this legendary bread helped china
win a war 500 years ago
so how can bread lead a country to
victory in battle you might ask
to find out we visited a bakery in fuon
china where mr huang and his family
specialize in making guangbang
[Music]
the year is 1563.
china is struggling to defend itself
against japanese pirates each night the
japanese pirates would sneak off their
boats and take whatever they could from
general qi's army
before the army even noticed the
japanese had vanished
somehow the pirates knew exactly where
the general's army was stationed every
time
turns out it was the campfires used to
cook their meals
they could cook this bread in an
underground clay oven so the soldiers
could make food without giving away
their location
oh and that hole in the middle that's
there so the soldiers could string out
the bread to carry around their necks
that's right a bread necklace
this created a portable food that
wouldn't slow them down during an ambush
and the legend lives on
thanks to local bakers who continue to
make guangbang the traditional way
once the signature hole is punched
through the middle each piece of dough
is stuck on the inside of a clay oven
heated by charcoal
[Music]
you can have it as a breakfast sandwich
with eggs
with pork fillings for lunch or simply
with green onions and bean sprouts for a
nutritious snack
whatever you choose it's delicious on
its own too
[Music]
so there you have it how a military
tactic to win a war became a beloved
snack
all thanks to general qi
hey everybody my name is drew bibi and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story